holy [ __ ] guys we just saw a documentary
people called poop talk poop talk guess
what it was about it was about people
talking about poop I like talking about
poop if you haven't seen my call me by
your name review you will know that I
like I like a good joke we got to watch
it early but it's actually being
available for release on video on demand
you could also buy it on iTunes be in
select theaters I'm February 16 so if
you're not watching Black Panther go
watch this documentary right here I mean
it's probably gonna try and beat them
out for the number one spot - might be a
close number - it actually cuts back and
forth between a lot of different
comedians primarily there's some other
people in there like dr. Drew Pinsky
doesn't know I think an endocrinologist
or in there at one point - talking about
couple science and anthropology
there's butterfly poop yeah and a lot of
this documentary touches on how we get
uncomfortable as a society to talk about
poop you know there's one of my favorite
parts about this documentary was talking
about how men view women when they poop
in like how we don't want to hear about
it you know that cliche the whole leg
man can open it whenever they want dudes
a free right to be disgusting and women
have women sterile but the fun thing
about this documentary is this whole
thing stays on topic it does not deviate
one bit talking about poop in the
different categories of it you know
between men and women the other
countries that use bidets oh I've used a
bidet it is there's a learning curve I
heard it's a pleasant experience once
you get over the initial shock of it all
yeah I used one and it was like wiggling
and giggling after a baganz until i
mind-over-matter dand was like no no
people enjoyed this we have to muscle
this documentary actually did get me
thinking in a weird way because nothing
about prism akin a way you see it
because I've talked to John about this
actually remember a little bit before
moving into this apartment it was a neat
estar John and I chillin
my bedroom I just brought up like how
come we're all uncomfortable to talk
about [ __ ] everyone does it you get
worse we're so uncomfortable to talk
about going to take a [ __ ] or [ __ ]
is just funny to people you know it's
just a funny thing to do when everyone
does it most people do it at least once
a day you precious little cultural
middle ground between disgusting and
hilarious yeah there's one thing you
can't escape and it's a point that gets
brought up multiple times it's it's one
of the few things that no matter who you
are you just have to do it we all do and
and the documentary approaches it from
all kinds of angles you learn people's
philosophies you hear what real-life
poop stories they talk to comedians who
come from other countries and stuff that
Camila and Johnny's face is all over
this but there are a few other people
too and they Bobby Lee's in it Bobby Lee
yeah and they tied there are even
campaigns all over the world to describe
people from pooping in the streets to
this day they do approach this topic
from every conceivable angle i really
quickly that the documentary is really
funny too because of the fact that
you're cutting back and forth doing a
lot of different comedians in there you
see Adam Carolla Aisha Tyler oh she's
hilarious yeah Rob Corddry has a lot of
moments in it Simon Rex is in it Nick
Swardson xin it paul shears in it Taryn
southern who had a famous music video on
YouTube after you oh yeah okay I'm gonna
prove after drinking coffee it got me
thinking about my childhood because we
were in an improv class yeah I thought
about this the entire fan improv class
when we were much younger at one point
we were required to actually experiment
with stand-up comedy and I wrote a whole
stand a bit about my biggest fear which
is still one of my biggest fears today
and that's having to go poop in someone
else's home for the first time cuz it's
all true you know the different
experiences like some people are so
comfortable talking about pooping and
some people are just really
uncomfortable with just even mentioning
or let it be known and some people are
on the take like one person the guy from
Modern Family who's featured in this
documentary talks about how he gets
timed when he goes to the back you have
people recognize you and they want to
talk to you because that's how it is
when you go to the go to
[ __ ] after the first minute and if you
haven't flushed everyone's gonna be like
ah shitty yeah everyone knows he's
[ __ ] or if you're with people and
you disappear for too long no you're
like I gotta come up with something I
they don't think I was I hate that
comment when you come back after a while
and someone's like you take [ __ ] you
take a [ __ ] yeah just like no matter
whether you did or not everyone's
thinking about you and poop together you
know this is the thing that in my life I
have kind of had a character arc about I
used to be one of those people who's
like I can only poop it home and then I
I actually had an out loud discussion at
work one day with a few people we
roundtable it sharing our thoughts on
pooping and somebody convinced me that
just the relief of it all is king and so
I've gotten a lot more loose about
pooping dude I'm all about pooping I
live with this guy I go like three to
four times a day I take a lot of five
rats I lost a bunch of weight man
regular baby I take so much probiotics
and fiber throughout the day I have many
a bowel movement and sometimes I just
feel like a champion because you know
when you have like a cheat day
and then the next day you take like a
lot of probiotics and fiber and you
drink a glass of cold water is the first
thing in the morning and then you look
in the toilet after and you're just like
on the trail right there that's a king
that I am king of Wakanda [ __ ] right
there's one story where this comedian
talks about basically pooping on an
airplane and eating a burger at the same
time and that's basically what we like
to do here yeah you know just keep it a
constant cycle it's a constant cycle
always regular sometimes I get so
stressed if I'm like in a long movie and
I have to go poop and if I don't go I
get a headache and then I've held it in
for so long then my butt and stomach
have just been like alright you ain't
gonna go at all tonight that hilarious
how you can get a headache from not
paying like somehow your body just like
crunches the signal up into your head
and those can't be good no they're not
this documentary made me think of
uncomfortable stories let's do it one
comfortable story start in second grade
I really have to take a crap and then
the teacher just wouldn't let me go to
the bathroom which is cruel if a kid has
to go to the bathroom that's a health
hazard if you don't let them go to the
bathroom and some teachers is just like
no
you'll go to the bathroom I took a [ __ ]
in my pants Oh No in class
it's like nastiest fart when you just
take a [ __ ] and you slowly see all the
other students heads turning like people
were gathering around me I never owned
up I wasn't like yeah I [ __ ] my pants I
was like you know I know I threw up
earlier myself and then wanting to bully
in the class Matthew barrage whoo I hear
is a hot life now he was even like I'll
sniff your butt right now let me sniff
your butt I'm like no sniff my butt
things kids do to solidify other kids
humiliation and discomfort so hard class
is so hard to clean cuz it's just like
caked into your everything it's the
second story that I have who's easily
the worst one
an ex-girlfriend who had a party at a
siblings place we all got drunk and we
crashed there that night and in the
morning I made it my goal to have a
hangover McDonald's breakfast I was the
first one away because before McDonald's
was doing all-day breakfast got about
like 7:00 in the morning got my
McDonald's but there were so many people
there I didn't go to take my morning ku
and oh and then I came back and the
front gate was locked I didn't want to
wake everyone no cuz I wasn't worried if
you were gonna judge you for getting
McDonald's and I tried calling people
but all their phones were dead just
everyone was a hack over Donna
you think I would have done that for
some reason when I got back I just
really had to go and I'm like I know if
I if I move I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants oh
you're you're hungover right like
there's anything happen to your so you
literally went in front of the apartment
yeah and sure enough I got a phone call
second later yeah it's way outside just
went to go grab some McDonald's for
myself my favorite parts were about the
men and woman in this documentary
because I've found that to be a strong
topic of conversation any relationship I
hop into oh yeah it's a hurdle everyone
must cry yeah I've never dated a girl
who's comfortable with just pooping and
letting me know although one time I did
date a girl who did not flush the toilet
and I walked in and one ahh
and I said come in here what is this you
you you doctor nice praetor I don't
think I've ever had this be a problem I
think every relationship I've ever had
is we've had just kind of a discreet
understanding of you know the excrete
activities we were about to you know
subtlety is the key this documentary
gets you thinking about a lot of things
because people find it to be such an
unattractive than me not everyone no but
it seems like the big general is a very
attractive very socially agreeable idea
that we were not flattered by our p.m.
mechanism because I think Aisha Tyler
brings it up in the documentary we see a
woman [ __ ] or we hear about her doing it
we're just like oh god now I'm gonna
imagine that when I'm having sex with
her guys we'll do it all the time and
just expect their chick to just have sex
with them whenever they want yeah I can
[ __ ] anywhere and talk about it with
full disclosure but you have to look
like poop in a bunker five blocks from
here and also the guys who like anal
only don't want [ __ ] damn damn bull you
gotta be just in order to take dudes who
want to experiment getting pegged and
you know you're not prepared I've heard
a few stories and I've heard a few
horror stories a few horror stories yeah
oh one time my girl is doing it to me
her finger and I felt like I had to go
to the bathroom I don't want to tell her
that cuz I was like maybe I want her to
do it again later so I just blamed it on
her nails wait one I was like oh it
hurts cuz your long nails ah okay when
really I was just like I'm gonna [ __ ] on
your hand right now I know I feel like I
know you even better no this documentary
is just a conversation starter it's a
compilation of so many different
thoughts and opinions and these the
different perspectives that all come
down to again of like why are we
uncomfortable with it and then a bunch
of funny poop stories it is a corner of
comedy it's a corner comic starting
pooping it is and there's ways to do it
work can be funny there are times where
it's not funny at all it just seems
cheap and lazy hearing some of the
stories here like there's some hilarious
[ __ ] that
some hilarious stories in here that are
just worth checking out that we wouldn't
want to ruin for any of you guys so I
thought for this video it was weak I
could do is share some of my own stories
and lie on inside and that's such a what
they're doing the documentary it's fun
to explore a topic like that that is
like so prevalent and somehow so taboo
and there's so much weirdness
surrounding it like it is one of the
weirder topics of human culture it's a
daily occurrence we have whole systems
for it and yet there's no baseline
understanding of how we all feel about I
don't know anyone who's ever been
comfortable enough to just go to a new
person's place for the first time and
just take a [ __ ] for like 10 to 20
minutes I could just relaxed it up
depending on whose place it is I can
make it quick
how close the bathroom is to where they
are no I can't if it's like a lady
romantically inclined in any in any
persuasion then yeah like it's gonna
take a while for me to release that
comfort I get uncomfortable because I
don't want to be viewed as ugly and
gross and gross yes so I feel like if
they know I took a [ __ ] people will be
like oh yeah they are and ugly people
operate Vanessa I think people will view
me get a handle on your anus when really
it's a healthy thing to do the bathroom
just a scary place man
I mean well then they also many of them
you pointed this out in your routine
like so many bathrooms have terrible
acoustics it's just like an echo chamber
you never want to go to a carpet because
if there's a mishap in the carpeted
bathroom yeah that oh no there's maybe
maybe a foot rug or something just for
appearance yeah yeah that's what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have the first
carpeted bathroom soundproof have a
combination recording booth bathroom yes
you can you know do voiceovers but also
crap in just the privacy of knowing no
one will ever hear it because it echoes
in there rarely is the bathroom door
next to the toilet there are whole
industries like of like sense and toilet
papers and like different attachments
for your toilet that whenever you smell
it you automatically
oh it's cuz they took a [ __ ] yeah y-you
smell Febreze in the bathroom oh they
took a [ __ ] that's just the first
thought it's the only time you smell
Febreze is it yeah like it messes with
your brain cuz then you realize oh
neutral is the only and they also
touched upon the idea which blows my
mind which is like recent knowledge that
apparently just Western toilets you're
just you're just in the wrong position
yeah I'm just not supposed to be sitting
down I've heard the best way to do it is
to squat well healthiest way and that
Western positions are the wrong way to
do it but I can't imagine doing actually
when I did do it outside that one
person's apartment I had to squat that
was easy we got to enjoy I think the
worst bathroom locks are the buttons you
know what I wish
where it's like is it locked you go with
the test if it's locked but do you do
that it unlocks the door yeah I have no
idea of actually telling you go and take
your [ __ ] in someone else's place always
a ninja experience you're trying to
master because you're timing yourself
because you've you go under a minute
people will think you took a piss some
people do that thing where they turn on
the sink in the bathroom and just run it
five minutes that's people know that
you're because you don't want people to
know that's that's the thing you got to
be discreet about it the worse though is
when it all doesn't flushes maybe you
can do it under a minute and get the job
done but one just like one little
floating piece you're like ah I got a
flush a toilet again now we're gonna
know see I dread the the the less than
considerate craps that come out in there
like you need to suspend time wiping
this a new cleansing yourself cuz then
you're like how much is it gonna take
when will it stop and we've all been
there you know we've all been there so
that's the stuff that like really
expands the experience out to me that's
worth you know like five minutes there's
worth two flushes yeah math of poop
discretion our goal with this video is
we're hoping they read it the
documentary before February 16th which
is today you got time it's digital throw
in our conversations in the middle of
all the other documentary interviews
they have going
we're gonna make our own YouTube version
of this talk yeah imagine this video but
with a bunch of different famous people
being there so the movie poop talk is
available on demand you can download it
off iTunes and also you can check it out
in certain theaters I'm telling you guys
it's worth watching it's a really really
funny documentary that surprisingly gets
you thinking about a subject that is
weirdly taboo hey man it is mankind's
most vulnerable insecurities I feel more
comfortable talking about sex than we
are hoping yeah and we're not even that
comfortable Society then imagine the
conversation about poop said no that's
the hardest talk to have all right guys
links in the description box to further
follow them hashtag poop talk subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification melba get notified every
time one of our videos is up well catch
you guys on the flippety-flip